hey reject nation my name is Greg Allen
and this is a review now let's just stay
silent for a minute and embrace that
hilarious opening bit that we just did
choreograph it's kind of like a kind of
I never rehearsed I'm gonna transition
can't right now I just showed her
Deadpool the musical guys and now we're
gonna watch Deadpool - the musical the
ultimate Disney parody you're a big
Disney fan aren't you you can't call
something ultimate Disney parody until
it has the castle stamp of approval
[Laughter]
never heard of the castle stamp of
approval
it needs a question mark with a little
asterisk that says pending castle
approval I got a patron of the day shout
out to do Joshua who's Sarah here's the
story every everyone who gets a shout
out on our patreon page I'm supposed to
do it for them in that month so he
pledged early June didn't realize this
till July oh this was a week ago week or
two ago hey Josh sorry for messaging you
ridiculously late shame on me Greg here
by the way I saw your joint early last
month and I never said hi we owe you a
mother flippin shoutout dude how are you
man where are you from because to give
him a shout-out I have to get to know
him right yeah then he says haha no
worries bro it's all good I love your
channel my man you guys are the best
which is why I just had a supporter
channel you know I just had had to
support your channel caps I'm actually
from Maui Hawaii and I never replied so
Joshua I messed up I just wanted to tell
you buddy I'm sorry for constantly
messaging you like I love you dude and
by association I'm gonna get to know you
better
we're gonna keep talking I'm replying
right when this videos done I don't want
you to think I forgot about you that's
why I'm here right now died saying I
love you good guy Greg let's finally get
around to this Deadpool musical play
that's right not safe for work
whoa oh [ __ ] they're happening up the
action here
[Music]
the first nobody okay
[Music]
clear yes it's me Dwayne Johnson eyes up
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] you buddy okay with you but we are
you suppose you like ha do you believe
I'm an x-men you [ __ ]
then take this powered evening Colorado
within a no mean girl I mean which one
are you after all your played by a
different Asian actors in every x-men
movie think saving me is gonna win you
any points with the x-men you're not a
superhero you're an actual murderer
maybe she's right
maybe is something amazing
[Music]
[Laughter]
wouldn't you think I'm number merc who
has everything
why does it seem you're all alone never
part of a team looking around here you
think yeah well
[Laughter]
I'm not sure
I wanna be where the heroes are breaking
or close aliquots
Oh magazine
teamed up with cap will be your Chuck
[Music]
Oh 18 ladies reference the kids love
them you are such I love it mean a
medley comes together Cyclops I mean
he's good on skin contact
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Lloyd wanted your stupid franchise
anyway they can't even keep their
timeline stream what about the Justice
League first what kind of sites DP
dildos delivery anytime anyplace any
hole an infant war you know I'm always
up for a good baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't do people get language Tony drop
that [ __ ] yeah give it a couple years
this is so cool is creative a [ __ ] list
right now get your break around here
these aren't the ones with marshmallows
ow where's the milk Oh
[Music]
whoa shitty rookie and alopecia you walk
I am home
let me guess Alpha Flight dumbass that's
sasquatch
I'm Pocky can you gain superheroes
sorry what you tell me
so Kmart Ryan Reynolds baby's got spice
so what's your song tiny dancer
[Music]
[Music]
nice marble daredevil show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow I'm so happy
[Music]
wait did they change it where is
Deadpool oh yeah did 14 princess
confirm no credits [ __ ]
[Music]
my gosh that's amazing Wow absolutely
amazing as absolutely amazing I'm just
gonna cut it for a second credit scenes
but I got I got opinions coming I know
Jubilee Jubilee number two I'll get her
to Jubilees all right group himself
great
Wow yeah I was I was also really
impressed with the gun fight scene in
the beginning well clearly this is these
are all professional yeah you know what
they're doing like I mean I should we
watch the first one that was my second
yeah watching it and I was like these
are all people that have worked on films
forever and they just came together and
did something really fun I hope that's
the case even if they're up and comers
even cooler speak about woody core I was
there I was pleasantly surprised overs
amazing like the first one was kind of
just a cool little skit and this was
this was like a musical short film okay
like it's like an action musical short
film I was pleasantly surprised by how
agrifim
[Music]
we think sounded really good the flick
yeah the music was all great
I've always people who always taking it
as a joke but I've always thought you
could pull off a musical comedy action
film and this was this is like a short
version of stuff I've kind of my guys
they got your reading still yeah come on
give us one more scenes
[Music]
oh man mother mother [ __ ] Brownlow to
that I have witnessed in a while there
was an actual narrative - he had a whole
journey that he had going on
they made a short film slash musical of
Deadpool also bringing together sort of
that dream that people wanted for
Deadpool to cross over into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so I was so happy
just seeing like the thought of it and
it was all in Deadpool fashion and from
beginning to end it was shot kind of
like two things to me some of the
lighting looked like the Deadpool 1 & 2
movie but it also kind of had a visual
comedy sense like an Edgar Wright film
the way the camera will pull your eye to
certain images and then the kind of cues
of the timing and the editing reminded
me of more of a kind of like an Edgar
Wright comedy mixed in with the Deadpool
style of humor well then were the
gunshots in time of the music I think so
you don't like they kind of work because
that's one of the whole thing was is
yeah like that's very much like it's
like so reminiscent of that it was super
sharp it's like some of the lighting
look like the Deadpool movies but the
visual comedy style not any more like
the right stuff to me this is a really
amazing fan films could have its own
series and I hope they kind of do that
one day that would be amazed that they
could pull it off the inclusion of like
the x-men making fun of the Jubilee the
multiple Jubilees that have been in the
x-men films the constant references but
I also love that you had a journey a
story of wanting to be a part of a team
and want any be a part about the
Avengers which you can relate to
regardless of if you're into
it's like everybody wants to be a part
of something yeah that's I think why
superheroes and comics and everything is
so relatable does that many people yes
because the unique thing about Deadpool
there's a heart to it and I think that's
why doing a musical comedy of Deadpool
is easy to latch on to because of the
fact that you're getting the heart our
humor of Deadpool with the heart of
Deadpool because that's naturally what a
musical would do and on top of that
these are parodies of very famous Disney
songs that are a great super gadget
super happy because the melody is
already great and then also just the
writing it's like they fit the songs or
perfect choices and yeah what was theirs
one line I can't remember but is
something it was like oh maybe he is
right maybe there is something in matter
with me I just don't see how we roll
with such wonderful things could be yeah
that's the beginning of a Little Mermaid
that's me that's you that's just it was
so well done the first one is really
impressive and very much very funny and
very cool yeah this is like a mission
they set needs to be recognized like
badly is it the people that did Deadpool
you think that right no it's not it
would make you think it's the people
that did Deadpool swear I thought that
it was nice outside Simona Moya who's
been on this channel a few times and who
I did improv when I was 16 now she's
starring in really popular internet
musicals we're not starring in really
cool Internet musicals no we can talk
about that's just as rewarding okay yeah
it should be about how why people save
rap rap rap rap rap rip rap rap from New
Zealand accent we say the first one was
a parody of the Gaston song for beating
the Beast right this one is the ultimate
Disney parody because of the fact that
Disney owns Marvel and Disney has now
bought Fox that owns Deadpool so
for some reason I didn't register that
so after we were done watching it
they're like doing ultimate dizzy parody
is brilliant it's like they make a
reference in it in the video but doing
uh doing that as your topic brilliant
yeah yeah Disney's great the solo movie
well you can follow its Amy castle on
Instagram I'm on YouTube too but I'm
more more current on Instagram I'm there
every day follow her on Instagram
try to the real reach okay
it checks out patreon full-length TV
show reactions weekly Q&A is music video
coverage love to have you become a
patron ejected a and if his and I'm one
of hers we pledge the same amount to
each other sort of breaking even every
Monday also if you haven't seen our
sketch please check it out put a lot of
hard work into it please check it out
love you
kind of I don't know most of you were
for real I love that you like me